I have some interesting clips for you.
A Fox News host, Chris Wallace, calling out
Republican Senator Tom Cotton for the obvious,
brazen, bold faced, stunning hypocrisy by
Republicans on the replacement of Ruth Bader
Ginsburg to the Supreme Court.
These clips I'm going to play for you are
not notable because we're shocked that Republicans
are being hypocrites.
The clips are notable because of how casually
and comfortably Republicans like Tom Cotton
use obvious bad arguments for why they couldn't
fill Antonin Scalia's seat back in 2016.
But now they should fill Ruth Bader Ginsburg
seat with only 45 days remaining before the
election.
Now, as a reminder, when Antonin Scalia passed
away during Barack Obama's presidency.
Republicans control the Senate as they do
now.
And they blocked the replacement of Antonin
Scalia with Merrick Garland, who is Barack
Obama's choice.
That was with nine months before the election.
Now we have just 44 days before the election.
And Republicans are saying now it makes perfect
sense for Donald Trump to replace Ruth Bader
Ginsburg.
So let's get into it.
Here is Chris Wallace.
Using Tom Cotton's own words against him or
at least trying to.
Back in 2016, after Justice Scalia died, President
Obama named Federal Judge Merrick Garland
as his new nominated the court.
And as you well know, you were part of the
Senate then.
Senate Republicans blocked the choice of Garland.
Here's what you said at that time.
A few short months, we will have a new president
and new senators.
You can consider the next justice with the
full face of the American people.
Why would we cut off the national debate about
this next justice?
Why would we squelch the voice of the people?
Why would we deny the voters chance to weigh
in on the makeup of the Supreme Court?
Now, Garland was nominated nine months before
the election and he was saying then, nine
months before the election, it was wrong to
deny voters a chance to weigh in.
So if it was wrong that nine months before
the election, why is it okay now, six weeks
before the election?
So, Chris, in 2014, the American people elected
Republican, a Republican majority, the Senate,
to put the brakes.
On President Obama's judicial nominations
in 2018, we had a referendum on this question
just a month before the twenty eighteen midterms.
We had that vote on Justice Kavanaugh.
There could not have been a clear mandate
because the American people didn't just reelect
Republicans.
They expanded our majority.
They defeated four Democratic senators who
voted against Justice Kavanaugh.
They reelected to one Democratic senator who
did vote for Justice Kavanaugh.
So we have a clear mandate to perform our
constitutional duty.
That's what the Senate majority will do now.
That's what we did back in 2016 as well.
This is one of the biggest logic pretzels
that I've ever seen from Republicans.
It actually might boggles the mind.
If you're not sure what Tom Cotton is talking
about, that's exactly the point.
It's meant to be confusing.
Let's think it through.
Tom Cotton says there's no hypocrisy here
because right after Kavanaugh's confirmation,
there was a midterm election in 2018 and Republicans
gained seats showing that the public had no
problem with the confident confirmation of
Brett Kavanaugh.
This is a complete non sequitur.
It has nothing to do with the issue at hand.
First of all, the Senate only has one third
of the seats up for reelection every election
cycle.
One third of the Senate is up for reelection
in any given election year.
In 2018, the Senate seats up for reelection
favored Republicans.
It had nothing to do with some kind of American
referendum on whether or not it was okay to
fill Brett Kavanaugh's seat.
I mean, it has it has nothing to do with it.
It is a complete and total red herring.
Secondly, this is about presidents, not Senates.
They said Obama can't pick someone during
his last year and now they're saying Trump
can pick someone during what are the last
44 days before the election.
It is incoherent.
And Chris Wallace calls him out.
You really don't think there is any hypocrisy
at all in saying we need to give voters?
Because, I mean, you can pass the 2014 election,
the twenty eighteen election any way you want.
But you stated a pretty firm principle in
2016 about Merrick Garland.
It's wrong to deny voters a chance to weigh.
And you don't see any hypocrisy between that
position then and this position now.
Chris, the Senate majority is performing our
constitutional duty and fulfilling the mandate
that the veteran voters gave us in 2016 and
especially in 2018.
I just want promises of the last question
on this particular subject.
Let's do a thought experiment.
You're a lawyer.
You do hypotheticals or you did when you were
in law school.
Let's assumed if President Trump were to lose
in the election six weeks from now, if the
Senate were to change hands so that it went
from Republicans to Democrats in a lame duck
session with a president who'd been defeated
and a Republican majority that was about to
be out of office.
When someone said the lamest of lame duck
session.
Are you saying you still think it would be
proper to vote to confirm President Trump's
nominee to the court, Chris, as I said, or
move forward without delay and there will
be a vote on this nominee.
These are just bad people.
That's it.
Chris Wallace exposes the hypocrisy he does.
I don't know that it matters to the Fox News
audience.
Donald Trump has coined this new refrain at
his rallies.
Fill that seat and they are moving forward.
And unfortunately, it looks like they're going
to have the numbers to do it.
So we can't control everything, but we can
control voting in November and we all need
to get out and vote to end this insanity.
They may get this seat filled.
They may not ultimately, you know, we can
only do so much and we should do whatever
we can do.
But they need to be punished.
Tom Cotton needs to be punished.
Lindsey Graham needs to be punished.
He's got an opponent, Jamie Harrison.
These people need to be held accountable for
their hypocrisy, for their brazen double standards.
And Chris Wallace is trying, but they just
don't care.
At the end of the day, they do not care that
they are obvious hypocrites.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at the Pacman.
Remember, you can get the daily audio podcast
anywhere
you want.
I tunes, stitcher, Spotify, Pandora.
Don't miss it.